[موسيقى]
افغانستان بلد تحكمه حركه طالبان بقوه
السلاح وحكم يقول لا مكان للنساء قيود
صارمه ابعدت النساء والفتيات عن الحياه
العامه
وحرمتهن من حقوقهن الاساسيه احدها الحق في
التعليم الا ان الافغانيات دافعنا عنه
بسلاح المدارس السريه في كل صباح باحد
افقر احياء العاصمه كابل تجتمع فتيات في
منزل للدراسه هو جزء من شبكه من ثمان
مدارس في خمس مدن تقدم خدماتها سرا
وبالمجان تدعمها منظمه افغانيات تعمل في
المناطق الشديده التاثر بحظر مدارس البنات
حظر طالبان لتعليم الفتيات تزامنا مع
سيطرتها على الحكم في افغانستان عام 2021
الا ان هناك ما يقرب من 250 امراه تاثرنا
بحذر طالبان للتعليم في التسعينات هنا
انفسهن باتنا ابحثنا عنهم مجددا في
المدارس السريه رغم الخطر الذي يواجه
المعلمات والطالبات الا انه هناك احنا
بالتعليم المتحديات احتمال التعرض
للاعتقال والقتل
ويتحايلنا على اعين عناصر الحركه باخفاء
ادوات التعليم وسلك طرق طويله ومختلفه
نتركوا كتبها في المنزل وفي الفصل اذا كان
لدينا واجب منزلي نكتبه على قطعه من الورق
بقلمنا ونضعه في جيبنا
امام المدارس السريه ليس سهلا اذ ان
سريتها ثاني عدم حصول الطالبات على شهادات
رسميه وتدق ناقوسم خوف ظهور جيل من
الفتيات عشنا حاضرا وسط الحرب والقمع
وبانتظارهن مستقبل رائع روان حمزه العربي
[موسيقى]